[Aplausos]
buenos días a todos tecnología
de qué os voy a hablar sabéis que hay
una tecnología que utilizáis mucho más
que la famosa internet los ordenadores
los teléfonos móviles y además nos rodea
constantemente en todos lados porque
estoy hablando de los leds los leds que
hemos utilizado hoy para linternas del
teléfono móvil las pantallas estos leds
que no están abismos rodeando y que son
muy eficientes porque no puedo veros
básicamente los leds que utilizamos para
controlarnos el pulso que me lo que
tiene que quitar por razones obvias o
los pasos
pero conocéis los leds muy bien sabéis
dónde vienen los leds quién fue el
primero que hizo un led
el silencio que se hace en mis clases
cuando hago una pregunta perfecto vamos
a ver los leds empezaron en el 1905
tuvieron dos investigadores más o menos
en paralelo uno que estaba en eeuu que
era joseph round y otro que estaba en
rusia que ahora lo sigue y estos dos
personajes eran muy curiosos que hacían
estos personajes bueno pues básicamente
cogieron minerales rocas como las que
tenemos en el museo de geología que
algunos habremos sido algunas tenemos
chicos bueno que esta gente cogía esos
minerales cogía las pinzas de las
baterías del coche para de cargar lo
colocaban ahí y empezaban a aplicar
voltaje bueno aplicaban 5 10 100 voltios
algunos minerales no hacían nada no es
nada sorprendente en ello y otros
empezaban a dar luz chispas de colores
de color naranja amarillo rojo y esta
gente escribía artículos científicos en
aquella época como podían y básicamente
desde escribía lo que hacían en cogido
este mineral y aplicado tanto voltaje
obtener este color
y al final del artículo siempre colocaba
una coletilla muy graciosa que decía si
alguien sabe qué está pasando que me lo
explique
eran científicos en aquella época claro
por qué digo esto de aquella época
porque claro la física tardó casi 20
años en llegar a describir lo que es la
teoría de los semiconductores después de
ellos qué es eso no os preocupéis
sencillamente explica que cuando tú
tienes un material le aplicas
electricidad te da luz o cuando lo
aplicas luz de la electricidad las
células solares y luego pasaron otros
décadas hasta que llegamos a la
nanotecnología que que significa
nanotecnología hacer cosas muy
pequeñitas claro que hacemos cogemos esa
piedra y hacemos una capa de 100
nanómetros y que se soluciona no metros
pues algo muy chico cogemos un pelo lo
miráis en el baño imaginar que lo
divides por 10 y lo que os queda son
aproximadamente unos 100 nanómetros
y a eso se dedicaba la gente hacer capas
muy delgadas y es seguir aplicando
voltaje con la mismas pintas del coche
un poco más refinadas obviamente claro
que hacían con esto pues obtuvimos el
color más o menos el color rojo en los
años 50 luego tenemos un amarillo en los
años 60 luego vino el verde y aquello
pues no quedaba más que como una especie
de bueno pues interesante no científicos
haciendo cositas interesantes con luces
porque porque la energía eléctrica era
muy mala tenemos la bombilla de edison y
funcionaba genial hasta que llegó a la
fuerza y la fuerte y yo hay un negocio
que cogieron cogieron los leds rojos
hicieron una tirita la colocan en la
parte de atrás de los coches los acordes
ahora de la parte de arriba de los
coches y dicen una aplicación
maravillosa para iluminar los coches
unos años después lo colocan aún delante
y nos hicieron el coche fantástico
con el que yo me he criado
pero pero el coche fantástico' de una
cosa muy interesante los leds se hacían
futuristas en la gente empezaba a ver
que los leds que llevaba ese scifinder
que tenemos ahora
bueno
claro fue los años más adelante ya los
años 90 cuando conseguimos el color azul
y ahora lo tenemos todo tenemos un azul
un rojo un amarillo y naranja que nos
falta señores el blanco
claro pero para hacer un blanco se
necesitan dos componentes un componente
que es un chip que va a emitir luz azul
el led azul y ahora yo a éste le voy a
colocar un filtro encima desde itrio
esta palabra la guardamos que lo que
hace es la luz azul parcialmente y
la voy a transformar en un amarillo
naranja y la combinación de ese azul y
el amarillo naranja nos da el blanco que
tenemos hoy en día un poquito más
mejorado
eso fue de los años 97 a partir de ahí
lo que hicimos fue básicamente pues
mejorar la tecnología la producción
aumentar su eficiencia bajar un poco el
coste la energía eléctrica ha ido
subiendo y subiendo y subiendo y eres
tan cara como el alquiler y entonces
pensamos hay que reemplazar las
bombillas es poco eficientes por los
leds los leds son muy eficientes y hay
que hacerlo vamos a ahorrar unos 14
billones de euros en europa al año somos
unos 750 millones de europeos pues
hacemos las cuentas dos euros por
persona es una hora más o menos
pero la pregunta que os quiero hacer no
es sobre esto sino son los leds que
tenemos hoy a aquellos que verán mis
nietos o los siguientes descendientes de
mi familia y las respuestas obviamente
no si no estoy aquí claro por qué porque
los dos tienen dos problemas un problema
de salud y un problema de sostenibilidad
ya os voy a contar uno a uno cada uno de
ellos la salud que lo más importante
sabíais que nos cuesta unos diez años
desarrollar el ojo durante nuestra
infancia por ello es tan importante
comer zanahorias crudas no hervidas
pues pensar que la razón que eso pasa es
porque el ojo también genera un filtro
un filtro que nos protege de la color
azul eso lo que vemos aquí lo que veis
la parte de arriba es como la luz azul
llega a los receptores que tenemos
detrás del ojo y ese filtro protege
entonces sí que es verdad que no hay que
mira la televisión tan cerca ni sobre
todo como tenemos 10 añitos y es la
razón por la cual mi abuela era una gran
científica también
y pensar también sois mayores de 50 años
bueno pues el filtro desaparece con la
edad entonces sí que es verdad que la
luz azul también promociona el
envejecimiento del ojo y otras
enfermedades asociadas al mismo con lo
cual necesitamos también protegernos y
si pensáis que este es entre 1050 y stei
salvados de la vida pues tampoco existen
efectos no visuales cuáles son esos
efectos no visuales pero aquellos
efectos que nos están afectando al
cerebro a la química del cerebro porque
la luz azul afecta la química del
cerebro por ejemplo a mi derecha lo que
veis es una persona que básicamente lo
que está haciendo es viendo una pared
blanca durante 10 minutos sin hacer nada
lo que veis es la actividad cerebral que
está generando lo que veis en medio es
la misma persona corriendo 20 minutos
generando endorfinas liberando estrés
porque está muy cansado el día su
actividad cerebral es vibrante muchísimo
colores y lo que tienes a la izquierda a
mi izquierda es sencillamente una
persona que está viendo una pantalla de
color led azul durante 20 minutos eso es
lo que es no visual lo que hace es esa
luz azul es estimular nuestro cerebro a
estar alerta y genera estrés
básicamente os despierta porque es la
componente mayoritaria de la luz del sol
a mediodía cuando teníamos que ir a
correr y teníamos que ser de caza es
decir el mensaje es que voy a decirles
si tú estás con la tablet por la noche
estás muy cansado y te estás eliminando
con luz azul tus ojos siguen cansados tú
estás cansado pero tú le está diciendo
el cerebro genera estrés una vez que lo
apagues el cerebro tiene que resetear se
lleva tiempo y es lo que nos afecta al
sueño pues al humor etcétera y se llama
el ciclo circadiano premio nobel 2017
muy bien sostenibilidad segundo problema
lo que estaba contando
bueno sostenibilidad pensar que nosotros
somos una sociedad tecnológica y como
tecnología entendemos que vamos a
la electricidad le vamos a llevar a
todos lugares del planeta con nosotros
porque queremos nuestra neverita en
nuestra televisión y nuestros leds
nuestro internet pues fijaos cómo luce
aquí la tierra desde la estación
espacial de noche luce bastante de color
amarillo es decir nuestro planeta azul
es más bien un planeta amarillo por la
noche
y pensar que vamos a todas esas
bombillas del mundo y las vamos a
transformar en leds y la pregunta que
nos tenemos que hacer es tenemos tanto
material para hacer eso
el lirio que era el filtro que os he
comentado que poníamos arriba ese
material tenemos 400 kilos toneladas del
mismo gastamos unos 25 kilos toneladas
al año en la producción del este hoy
vamos a hacer las cuentas y además no se
recicla de forma eficiente bueno se
verifica casi nada
además pensar de dónde viene el itrio
por si el itrio viene de los meteoritos
cuando la tierra se estaba formando es
lo que hay y está o hacemos un arma que
nos vamos a buscar a otro esteroides o
no hay más hito en el planeta
y de hecho el planeta donde está está
muy localizado y eso no es un cohete de
un meteorito
sino una mina
lo que hicimos es básicamente sacar el
litri o el óxido de litio y hacemos un
agujero precioso en un ambiente
paradisíaco si lo queremos ver
además no se refina el sitio hay que
transportar los lugares donde hay países
donde la energía eléctrica es muy barata
como los años 50 y lo tenemos que
refinar y luego lo transportamos a otros
lugares del mundo para poder venderlo
todo eso genera una huella ecológica muy
grande que no estamos tiene en cuenta
bueno y aquí es donde tenemos el
problema y nueve kilos de nosotros
materiales y en mi grupo buscamos
soluciones hay muchas soluciones y mucha
gente trabajando que nosotros nos
planteamos como hace la luz
nuestra naturaleza y no me refiero al
sol sino lo que veis aquí debajo del mar
un dato curioso es que tres de cada
cuatro animales que existen en el mar
emiten luz por alguna razón bien sea
para protegerse bien sea para llamar a
otros a otros amigos bien sea para
comunicar comida o bien sea para
comunicar pareja o bien se para decir
que me estoy muriendo no vengáis por
aquí y como hace el luz estos animales
pues es muy similar lo que hacemos
nosotros una reacción química
emite luz azul de alta potencia y unos
filtros de proteínas y las proteínas lo
que hacen las absorben ese azul y lo
transforman en muchos colores diferentes
para comunicar mensajes diferentes a las
diferentes lugares y encima a largas
distancias porque tiene que comunicarse
a las distancias cada aquí está el
paralelismo señores un led que emite luz
azul y un filtro que colocamos encima
una reacción química azul y un filtro
encima porque no puedo este filtro
y llevarlo aquí a mis leds
es decir cómo puedo mis proteínas
que están diseñadas para estar dentro de
los organismos centros rodeadas de agua
por eso nosotros vemos 2 litros de agua
al día y los leds no quieren tener agua
y una sola gota
cómo podemos hacer ese puente entre el
mundo biológico y el mundo de los leds
bueno pues ese puente pero que nosotros
llamamos polímeros que son plásticos
básicamente y lo que hacemos es diseñar
los polímeros que cogen a mis proteínas
las abrazan las estabilizan fuera de
agua y las llevan a mis manos para hacer
tecnología les voy a enseñar
esto que veis aquí son proteínas metidas
dentro de esos plásticos o polímeros y
lo que veis aquí abajo es la luz verde
que se genera que es lágrima de luz
verde que utiliza las medusas por
ejemplo para comunicarse
y esto ya tiene cuatro añitos y va
conmigo todos los
claro como luces en un dispositivo pues
para eso están estos vídeos de aquí os
enseño
donde básicamente lo que veis aquí es
una proteína que emite luz de naranja y
abajo es un led de color azul es un
filtro sencillamente lo aquí tenéis una
proteína de color verde y lo que veis
abajo sé que es internet azul y si
combinas estos dos colores tenéis este
led blanco maravilloso que es el que
utilizamos en nuestro laboratorio y
analizamos nuestro primer dispositivo
que vio unas 150 horas que no es mucho
con una luz no me distancia bastante
buena para las casas y ahora ya estamos
en seis meses de estabilidad y hemos
hablado de la eficiencia del mismo pero
qué más se puede hacer con estos leds
con estos filtros de proteínas las la
ventana solar que es eso
imaginaros un marco de una ventana
los dos vidrios del marco de la ventana
y ahora voy a un plástico
transparente con proteínas y lo voy a
colocar en medio el rayo del sol va a
llegar a la luz ultravioleta va a
disfrutar mis proteínas va a enviar luz
a los bordes no detengo células solares
y esa energía la vuelco a mi casa la
webcam usb como se ve son la realidad
pues también los tengo unos granitos
mirar esto es un filtro totalmente
transparente porque veis mis dedos
ves que se iluminan los bordes así es
como luce
colocamos las células solares los bordes
y esa energía la podemos transformar en
electricidad
qué más podemos hacer hablando de
diversidad como estamos hoy hablando
pues pensar que los puentes son muy
buenos para unir personas una tecnología
la biología y la optoelectrónica pero
podríamos otras personas nos encontramos
en medio del puente con los biólogos y
después de muchas peleas de vocabulario
y alguna cerveza que otra somos capaces
de entendernos y un biólogo puede
empezar a pensar que sus proteínas que
estaban haciendo pues podrían ser
aquellas que se puedan utilizar día de
mañana en un led o podemos evolucionar
por ejemplo la biología pensando que
necesitamos tecnología para células
solares y para leds y un tecnólogo que
siempre había pensado que la biología no
sirve para nada por si sirve para mucho
es una de las cosas que hicimos por
ejemplo todos juntos fue elaborar una
proteína de luz blanca porque a natureza
no le pita blanco para nosotros y eso en
las cosas que hemos hecho ahora y
estamos diseñando y mejorando
entendiendo cómo se degradan y avanzando
bueno mi tiempo llega a su fin
y lo que quería comunicarlo son
básicamente dos mensajes para acabar un
mensaje es particular de los leds es
obviamente señores pues la tecnología
led que tenemos hoy no basa la
tecnología led que vean mis nietos sea
la que dé a mi hijo pero no de mis
nietos ni de mis bisnietos
tenemos que pensar que o bien reducimos
itrio que es una solución o bien
reciclamos que es importante reciclar
por califica nos va a dar tiempo para
poder desarrollar otras alternativas y
el auto alternativa lo que se presentado
yo y otra gente que estamos trabajando
buscando materiales que sean sostenibles
y que se puedan aplicar a esta
tecnología y ahí vamos a la parte final
de la general que es básicamente deciros
que toda tecnología toda tiene cuatro
estadios de evolución una es la
seguridad otra es la estabilidad otras
la eficiencia sobre todo energética y
uno que estamos ahora empezando que son
más conscientes que nunca que es la
sostenibilidad tenemos que utilizar
desarrollar tecnología que use
componentes materiales que no sean que
no comprometan básicamente el futuro de
nuestros nietos muchísimas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]